support the production of more videos by
visiting the support move section on our
website the link is in the description
below thank you and enjoy so in this
video I kind of want to think about how
we can look back at dalton's original
atomic theory and compared to what we
know now so these are as postulates that
I mentioned in one of the earlier videos
and we're going to discuss them now so
he initially stated that all matter
consists of tiny indivisible particles
those a keyword called atoms ok and he
was right about all matter containing
little particles called atoms but they
are not indivisible atoms are divisible
right into the subatomic particles
protons neutrons and electrons however
something that's pretty important is
that atoms are the smallest entity that
retains and elements unique properties
so what basically what i'm trying to say
there is that an atom is the smallest
thing that has unique properties like
protons are protons are protons
regardless of which ad on their in
electrons the same way neutrons are the
same way they don't differ from atom to
atom leave my different number and the
amount of them from atom to atom but
each electron is the same age protons
the same but atoms are the smallest
things that have particular unique
properties right like an atom of oxygen
is different than an atom of gold okay
so he was close there but not quite
right about the indivisible sort of
situation next thing was that atoms of
the same element are identical in mass
and other properties and are different
from atoms of other elements he's not
quite right about this one atoms are
identical in number of protons right not
mass this is because isotopes exist
right you can have different masses
different mass numbers but have the same
atom by the same same element ok but he
is right about them all atoms having
particular identities that are different
from other elements this next thing
about atoms of an element chemically
combining in specific small whole-number
ratios to form different chemical
compounds pretty much correct about that
really hasn't changed very much atoms
are recombined in chemical reactions
atoms of an element are not converted
into atoms of a different element so
this the first part is correct right
this first part about recombining in
chemical reactions that's true atoms of
an element are not converted into atoms
of a different element that's not quite
right right because atoms of an element
are not converted to atoms of another
element in chemical reactions but this
can happen in nuclear reactions which we
have yet to go over but the point is
that atoms can be converted atoms over
to element can be converted into atoms
of a different element but not via
chemical reactions only via nuclear
reactions so he was right about some
stuff wrong about some stuff but the
point is that you kind of started things
as far as developing the atomic theory
and we've come a long way since then so
hope that video was helpful and kind of
understanding how we look at dalton's
theory now thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
hit with a like and subscribe for more
content also followed with University on
the different social media links in the
description below thanks and happy study